Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wie ist die Lage?
Na ja, es ist ja doch wieder einiges passiert.
Was ist ein Buch mit, das die Lage heißt?
März hat ja versucht, noch einen weiteren Antrag durchzudrücken, ist aber dann gescheitert.
Wir müssen jetzt ganz genau sein. Anträge, ja. Das erste war ja ein Entschließungsantrag. Also alle Welt wusste, macht keinen Sinn, ist nicht mal ein Eckpunktepapier, ist einfach nur ein Appell. Der ging ja durch.
Ja.
Und das zweite war ja ein konkreter Gesetzesvorschlag. Der beinhaltete Grenze zu, Ausländer raus, niemand darf hier rein, ich hasse Menschen, ich mag das nicht, bitte macht alle mit, sonst machen wir es mit der AfD. Ja. Und sehr viele FDPler haben sich gesagt, ne doch nicht und auch die CDU war nicht geschlossen, anwesend.
Die Szenen haben glaube ich gefehlt bei der FDP12 etwa, was schon recht viel ist. Die AfD hat zugestimmt der Sache, BSW hat sich auch positiv dazu verhalten, was wirklich schrecklich ist. Interessant ist aber jetzt folgendes, der Stern hat recherchiert, ein Tag zuvor, also man sagt, es gibt diesen Tabubruch, den März da plant, wir müssen auch Demos machen und so weiter, einen Tag zuvor.
Also einen Tag vor dem Entschließungsantrag, der durchging oder?
Nein, vor diesem Gesetzesänderungsantrag.
Ausländer-Rausgesetz.
Sagen wir es so, ja wie es ist. Folgender.
Wir können es natürlich auch, das macht es aber nicht besser, Zustrombegrenzungsgesetz nennen. Das ist quasi Ausländer-Rausgesetz. Die Natur, der Strom, die Gewalt.
Und wir haben ja schon gehört, bei Markus Lanz war Habeck zu Gast, dass Habeck durchaus bereit war mit Merz zu diskutieren und zu telefonieren und Gemeinsamkeiten zu finden. Aber wie das so sich anhörte, wollte Merz nicht mit Habeck telefonieren oder nicht privat sprechen.
Die reden nicht.
So. Ist doch schon mal interessant, dass die Grünen so einen Schritt überhaupt dann auf Merz zugehen und sich dann auch die Frage stellt, warum ist Merz dann nicht gewillt, einen Kompromiss zu schließen? Denn alles, was dann Habeck vorgeschlagen hat, klingt zwar sehr viel höflicher, meint aber sehr häufig auch eher Ausländer lieber draußen bleiben. Und da ist doch interessant, dass also ohne Not quasi Merz das so eskalieren ließ, wo man sich fragen kann, warum? Welcher strategische Plan ist das? Ist das vielleicht der Plan zu sagen, wenn ich jetzt tatsächlich einen sehr scharfen Anti-Asylkurs mit den Grünen zusammen als Kompromiss präsentiere, wird man mir aus der rechten Blase sagen, ich bin eingeknickt vor den Grünen? Oder ist es wirklich so, dass man von Merzseite aus sich sagt, ich versuche doch noch einen Schritt weiterzugehen? Insofern, als ich mal schaue, wie ist die Reaktion darauf, wenn das nochmal mit der AfD hier versucht wird, ist das vielleicht doch auf Dauer eine Option für die CDU, weshalb ja dann jemand wie Michel Friedman, Jahrzehnte in der CDU ausgestiegen ist?
Also meine Vermutung ist, ich hab jetzt alle Männer-Podcasts dazu gehört, also den von Gordon Rybinski und den von Michael Brücker und den von Robin Alexander und den von Paul Ronsheimer. Wir hören auch heute Clips, die ein bisschen damit zu tun haben. Alle sagen, Friedrich Merz hat ja nicht so richtig Regierungserfahrung. Also der kann halt eine Kanzlei leiten und selbst in diesem BlackRock-Aufsichtsrat-Chef war es mehr so, wir brauchen dein Adressbuch und dann stellen wir fest, du hast eigentlich gar keins, müssen wir so tun als ob und dann ist er da in zehn Jahren irgendwie. Und Friedrich Merz hat wohl Orientierung gesucht und sie im Fernsehen gefunden, das kennen wir ja von Donald Trump, wacht morgens auf, weiß nicht, was soll er halt machen, schaltet Fox ein und dann wird ihm erklärt, was er machen muss. Und er sieht dort Donald Trump, der sagt, am Tag eins bin ich Diktator, das ist kompromisslos und so weiter und er kopiert genau das, er übersetzt es nur auf Deutsch, aber es ist sozusagen in der gleichen Blöderheitsklasse. Und er sieht Österreich und weiß, der Kiekel kann jetzt mit 28 Prozent eine Kanzlerschaft aufbauen. Gelingt ihm noch gerade nicht so gut, aber mal gucken, was die Verhandlungen da bringen. Also mit 28 Prozent kann man selbst als AfDler, als FPÖler Kanzler werden. Dann schaff ich das doch als CDUler allemal. Ich muss nur sozusagen langsam vorbereiten, aber man kann...
Und meine Partei von 32 Prozent den Umfragen auf 29 Prozent bringen.
Genau, also man bringt sich erstmal auf 28 Prozent wie die FPÖ und dann macht man das irgendwie. Aber man muss halt die Radikalität darstellen und so meinen und vehement durchprügeln. So wie Kicke. Niemals zurückstecken. Wenn die Medien sagen, das ist scheiße, double down. So und das ist März Strategie aus Orientierungslosigkeit. Wir können auch sagen, heute haben wir ja ein Salon, der uns das Wort dumm auf Grundbegriffsebene politischer Beobachtung holt mit Marc Schiritz. Deswegen, das ist halt wahnsinnig dumm, was März da macht. Aber das heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass das heute im politischen Felde, wie es ist, nicht von Erfolg gekrönt ist. Am Ende will er nur Kanzler werden.
Ja, vieles ist so dumm.
Weitern ist es ja egal. Er will nur Kanzler werden.
Dumm ist das interessante Wort. Mir hat ein Bekannter aus Wien geschrieben, die FPÖ erwägt, hierzulande Deutsch als vor der Schule verpflichtend einzuführen, sowie universitäre Abschlussarbeiten nur auf Deutsch zu erlauben. Das wäre das Ende der Unis, da wir wohl gut die Hälfte der Doktoranden und damit einen substanziellen Teil der Forschungsleistung damit verlieren werden. Und trotzdem gibt es eben diese Bestrebungen. Natürlich versuchen sich vor allem die Unis dagegen zu stellen. Aber ja, und für ihnen bedeutet das auch, dass dann eine deutsche Pflicht, ja, ihnen dazu bringen würde, dann darüber nachzudenken, Österreich zu verlassen und dass das überhaupt das österreichische Geistesleben sehr stark dezimieren würde. Und jetzt frage ich dich aber, wenn wir das so mitbekommen. Und wir sagen, also wie der Diskurs ist, also der nicht rechte Diskurs ist, Tabubruch, Brandmauer eingestürzt etc. Und dann bekommen wir von einer Sternrecherche folgendes. Nach Sterninformationen lud der frühere CDU-Chef Armin Laschet am Donnerstagabend, also am Vorabend zu diesem Showdown, zu einem Treffen in seiner Berliner Wohnung, bei dem mehrere hochrangige Schwarz-Grüne Politiker anwesend waren. Zu den Gästen zählten Top-Grüne wie Annalena Baerbock, Cem Özdemir und Kathrin Göring-Eckardt. Auf CDU-Seite waren unter anderem Kanzlerkandidat Friedrich Merz und der frühere Gesundheitsminister Jens Spahn dabei. Das schon länger geplante Treffen hieß Auf ein Glas mit Armin Laschet. Das hieß Auf ein Glas mit Armin Laschet, wäre bestimmt auch eine schöne Sendung im WDR. Ich bin gespannt. Will aber hier keine Ideen geben. Jedenfalls, was machen wir jetzt mit dieser Meldung? Sagen wir, ach toll, dass die noch miteinander reden, das gehört ja in der Demokratie dazu. Und wir würden erstmal sagen, ja natürlich müssen die noch irgendwie miteinander reden und die könnten ja auch möglicherweise Koalitionspartner werden. Aber welches Theater beobachte ich dann in den sozialen Medien, im Bundestag und sonst wo, wenn genau diese Politiker sich gegenseitig bekämpfen, als seien sie der Todfeind, der jetzt alles einreißt und kaputt macht. Also entweder ist es ein Tabubruch, dann kann man doch nicht dann abends feiern gehen. Also die haben, ich will das nochmal deutlich machen, es geht ja hier nicht um eine inhaltliche Auseinandersetzung, bei der man sagt, da sind wir anderer Meinung. Also wir könnten uns jetzt, weiß ich nicht, hier zanken über die Höhe der Einkommenssteuer und da würde kein Platt mehr dazwischen passen. Dann könnten wir ja trotzdem danach essen gehen. Aber es ist ja doch was anderes, wenn ich sage, ich paktiere jetzt mit der AfD, da würde man nicht sagen, naja, ist aber trotzdem alles super auf ein Glas Wein los mit Armin Laschet. Und das finde ich doch so, dass man hier den Eindruck gewinnt, also wird irgendwo Theater gespielt, entweder in der Wohnung von Armin Laschet, was ich nicht glaube, oder es wird doch Theater gespielt bei dieser Empörung.
Also was wir sehen ist die hohe Attraktivität von Macht per se. Anna-Lena Bärböck will einfach nur Außenministerin bleiben, Scholz will einfach nur Kanzler bleiben, Merz möchte Kanzler werden und Armin Laschet, keine Ahnung, alle haben ja Vorstellungen, auch Ricarda Lang kann man ja offenbar aus diesem Amt da raus drängen, durch ihre eigene Partei. Und dann ist sie halt einfach weiter die Twitter-Vorsitzende von den Grünen. So sie bleibt einfach und spielt das Medienspiel weiter. Im Gespräch bleiben für den Fall, dass mal wieder Posten aufgehen und irgendwelche Verlierer aussettiert werden oder so. Ich will mal anknüpfen an Wien einfach als Hashtag, um zu klären, was passiert da in dieser kleinen Wohnung. Ja. Wien vor 100 Jahren war ja der Zufluchtsort für alle, in die in Gedanken waren. Also ich weiß noch mein Musiklehrer damals, als wir uns alle so fragten, wo und wann würden wir gerne mal leben, kamen wir dummen Schüler natürlich so New York, alle wollen nach Hongkong, keine Ahnung. Und er so Wien vor 100 Jahren. Also sozusagen Zustroben der ganzen Welt nach Wien. Wenn wir heute Wien sagen, schwingt das immer noch mit. Wien ist eigentlich nicht Österreich, Wien ist viel mehr als Österreich. Wien das ist unser, jetzt liegt es ja weit im Osten, das ist eigentlich das Europa. Sloterdijk hätte irgendwann mal gesagt, heute ist es die Ostküste Amerikas, damals war es Wien. So ungefähr, auf der Ebene reden wir über Wien. Wenn jetzt in Wien in die Regierung an den Start geht, die sagt, in unseren Universitäten bitte nur noch auf Deutsch Abschlussarbeiten schreiben, was ein Abschiedsbrief an die ganze Welt darstellt, also kommt nicht nach zu uns, wir sind jetzt nur noch Wien, wir sind nicht mehr Wien. So und jetzt dieser Transfer nach Deutschland, eigentlich ist Deutschland, fühlt sich auch immer so ein bisschen Wienerisch an.
Ja ja.
Exportweltmeister, den Holocaust zum einen veranstaltet, sind wir nicht so stolz drauf, aber diese Aufarbeitung, wir sind sozusagen das Schlagen der Herz der Menschlichkeit der Welt, wir sind das Vorbild und so.
Ja und Berlin ohnehin die 20er Jahre und all das.
So und jetzt wird aber die Zukunft Deutschlands ausgeklüngelt in einem schwarz-grünen Bündnis, das sich nicht traut ehrlich damit umzugehen, dass das Problem, was die Schwarzen da verursacht haben, natürlich nicht das gemeinsame Abstimmen ist mit der AfD, sondern ein Gesetz vorzulegen, bei dem die AfD einfach sagt ja machen wir, weil es ja unverkennbar ist ja unser. Ja. So also alle reden gerade über die Brandmauer, aber dass die CDU schon längst allein über die Ausformulierung so eines Gesetzes und sich zu trauen das auch als Vorschlag in den Bundestag zu bringen, wo einfach drinsteht, wir machen alle Grenzen zu und wir sind da auch so.
Und wir haben vor vielen Monaten mal einen Clip gespielt von Bas und Proc, der sagt das Schlimme ist, bitte AfD, dass alle Politiker es sich jetzt leicht machen können. Sie deklarieren, dass sie nicht AfD sind, weil die AfD sind die Rechten, das sind die Nazis. Deshalb ist alles, was wir tun, egal wie scharf unsere Antiflüchtlings Gesetze sind, immer auf der richtigen Seite, weil es sind nicht AfD Positionen. Die AfD ist die böse Seite, wir sind die gute Seite. Und das finde ich auch, dass inhaltlich gar nicht darüber diskutiert wird. Und man ja sogar sieht an den Zugeständnissen, die dann Habeck in so einem Interview macht, oder auf die man von Franziska Brandt hört, dass man offenbar sagt, na generell sind wir eigentlich schon für diesen Rechtsruck inhaltlich, nur formal hat es uns nicht gepasst, dass das mit der AfD stattfindet. Und das ist das Skandalöse und das muss man auch noch mal den Leuten zu klären, weil das auch in vielen Podcasts so durcheinander geht. Es ging nicht um irgendeine Abstimmung, die vernünftig war, wo man sagt, ja genau, es wäre gut, wir haben keine Sommer- und Winterzeit mehr. Und da hat jetzt auch die AfD ihre Stimmen dazu gegeben und damit ist sie Adakta Sommer- und Winterzeit. Ja, da würde man sagen, okay, völlig egal. Hätte man nicht machen müssen, na ja. Hier haben wir es mit einem inhaltlichen AfD-Gesetz zu tun, das dann auch von der AfD gotiert wurde natürlich.
Bodo Ramelow sitzt in der Bundesbritannien-Konferenz und sagt, also in Thüringen gehen jetzt 300.000 Menschen in Rente und es kommen aber nur 150.000 nach. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Flüchtlingsdiskussion, wie wir sie gerade führen, den Kern der deutschen Probleme betrifft. Ja. So und man denkt sich so, ja genau das ist das Thema. Hoch abstariert auf ganz Deutschland, so und so viele Menschen gehen in Rente, nur halb so viel, kaum nach. Wir lesen heute dieses sehr gute Buch Gemeinsinn. Also ein fantastisches Buch, es ist für mich Augenhöhe mit Grabbers, Anfänge und so weiter. Naja, es ist wirklich spektakulär. Aleida und Jan Aßmann haben den halben Salon gelesen. Also alles was wir lesen kommt da wieder vor. Die lesen Oschmann, die lesen Triggerpunkte, also die lesen einfach alles so. Und sie lesen auch Carl Schmitt. Und Carl Schmitts Definition von was ist ein Arya ist, naja, ein kein Nicht-Arya. So, ja also was ist das Deutsche, naja das ist nicht Jüdische, also der wird einfach so Zwangsalternativen aufgebaut. So, das auf heute transportiert stellt uns ja wirklich wieder die Frage, sind wir wieder da angekommen? Ist eine demokratische Politik einfach demokratisch, weil sie nicht AfD ist? So wie du es eben beschrieben hast. Und die AfD macht einfach immer was die AfD macht und wir sind einfach nicht die AfD. So, das ist die Argumentation. Ja, könnten Sie uns das noch ein bisschen ausführen? Reicht Ihnen das nicht, nicht die AfD zu sein? Also haben wir nicht die Diskussion, diese moralische Fernab aller politischen Inhalte so weit getrieben, dass es Ihnen einfach reicht zu wissen, na hauptsache nicht AfD, so, ne? Und da sind wir ja genau nicht. Der Punkt ist ja, die CDU macht AfD-Politik. Das wird gar nicht diskutiert, weil alle über die Brandmauer und ja, die CDU ist aber nicht die AfD, die aber in diesem Gesetzestext steht, wir machen die Grenzen zu, wir bewachen 3.800 mit Gewalt Kilometer und niemand kommt hier rein und alle die da sind werden auch nochmal hinterfragt, ob sie denn damals zurecht kamen, vielleicht nehmen wir ihnen den Pass wieder ab und lauter so ein Scheiß, ja. Also das ist doch AfD-Politik. Jetzt kann noch keiner kommen und sagen, puh.
Bei Straffähigkeit passend zu Zug und all diese Dinge, Jens Spahn führt es ja dann auch nochmal aus.
Also die CDU ist jetzt die AfD und nicht, ahja, da müssen wir uns mal über die Brandmauer Gedanken machen oder so. Nein, das ist doch längst geschehen. Also diese Grenzüberschritte intellektuell sind doch längst gegangen.
Und gibt es nicht vielleicht auch ein Problem, dass viele Sympathisanten von AfD-Positionen, nennen wir es jetzt einfach mal, egal ob sie jetzt von CDU oder AfD selbst vertreten werden oder dann auch von den Grünen mitgemacht werden. Und der SPD geht ja da auch gerne weit, wie wir ja schon während der Ampelkoalition gesehen haben. Also es war jetzt nicht so, als wäre das eine migrationsfreundliche Politik, die jetzt beendet wird. Und dann haben wir aber interessante Umfragen. Es gab so einen kleinen Bericht bei SWR 4 über die sogenannten Deutsch-Russen oder Russland-Deutschen, die durchaus in Umfragen zur AfD tendieren und sehr konservative Positionen einnehmen. Wir haben...
Wie relativ viele islamischen Völkern.
Wir haben eine AfD, die sich gerade unter Maximilian Krah stärker nach Türkei ausrichten will. Was interessant ist, weil du auch den Diskurs kennst der Nullerjahre von Rechtsradikalen. Es gibt zu viel Türken im Land oder sowas haben die vorhin nicht gegeben. Jetzt ist ja so die Türkei und sind die Türken Verbündete im gemeinsamen Kampf gegen liberale Demokratie oder Genderwahn oder was auch immer. In Anführungszeichen natürlich jetzt gesetzt. Und dann haben wir ein Video, das viral geht, dass dieser auch sehr abgedriftete Moderator Achim Winter eine POC auf der Straße anspricht und zu März und der Brandmauer befragt und sagt Nein, alles richtig, die sollen mal Deutsch lernen, sich benehmen und so weiter. Und dann haben wir noch, das ging jetzt gestern glaube ich rund, von einer schwulen Dating Plattform namens Gay Romeo. Eine Umfrage haben die gemacht, wen die Leute da wählen. Allerdings konnte man wohl da freiwillig sich, also konnte man freiwillig abstimmen, es war jetzt nicht irgendwie, man wurde nicht angerufen oder dergleichen. Und das wurde von von Focus Online und so weiter aufgegriffen. 28 Prozent, 29 Prozent für die AfD. Dann noch mal ein großer Satz für die CDU.
Jetzt wunderst du dich darüber, dass Menschen nicht nur im ökonomischen Feld gegen ihre Interessen wählen, sondern auch auf anderen auch noch auf diesen auch noch auf diesen.
Also das ist ich finde es. Na was heißt wundert mich? Ich finde es erstaunlich erst einmal, dass es einen solchen Rechtsruck gibt, auch bei Gruppen, wo man eigentlich denken würde, naja, die würden ja von einer an sich progressiven Politik doch profitieren. Jetzt gibt es natürlich, werden jetzt sofort Leute sagen, ja, aber es gab doch immer wieder auch so Leute wie Harpe Kerkeling und so, der jetzt nicht rechts ist, aber der dann sagte, er fühlt sich nicht mehr so wohl in Berlin und das sei problematisch, wenn er da mit seinem Partner Händchen halt über die Straße geht. Und ich glaube auch, dass das ein Problem ist, also dass das jetzt nicht rein imaginiert ist. Aber ich finde interessant, dass man dann so weit geht, ob man jetzt Migrationshintergrund hat oder eine nicht heteronormative Lebensweise an den Tag legt, dass man dann so weit geht und sagt, man wählt AfD.
Ja, da muss ich dich immer wieder begeistern und faszinieren für ein großes Thema Familie. Denn es ist ja nicht nur Marke Thetscher, sondern es ist auch Philipp Hopf, der in seinem Podcast immer wieder betont, wähle was das Richtige ist für dich und deine Familie. Jetzt ist es so, egal wo du herkommst, ob aus der Türkei, aus Ghana, wie auch immer, so nach einer Zeit hast du dich in den Sing-Sang in Deutschland eingelebt und dann weißt du, alle sind für Familie. Und wenn jemand ein zweijähriges Kind töte, dann weißt du, das geht gegen ihn und gegen uns alle als Familie. Das war quasi unser Kind, hat ja Markus Söder gesagt. So er hat es aus unserem Schoß gerissen. Wir wollten es noch lieben. Wohin jetzt mit unserer Liebe? Er hat uns das Kind genommen. Also dieses, wir kommen daher ausführlich drauf zurück, Karl Schmidt, die Juden zwingen über die Nürnberger Prozesse der Welt ihre Moral auf. Schon wieder werden wir von ihnen besiegt. Dieses Gefühl.
Das ist da Karl Schmidt.
Genau. Das finden wir immer wieder, überall. So wir kennen dieses Phänomen auch aus Amerika.
Das ist unabhängig erstmal von der Identität. Also ich finde, dass diese Sachen, die ich jetzt gerade vorgetragen habe, das streicht quasi nochmal eine gewisse Identitätspolitik durch. Also ich glaube, man hat sich bei der Identitätspolitik sehr lange darauf konzentriert, dass man glaubte, wenn alle repräsentiert sind oder so, dann gibt es eine generell fortschrittliche Entwicklung. Und dass dies aber nicht der Fall ist, das sehen wir da sehr deutlich. Und das sind glaube ich nicht nur Schlaglicht. Und man wird sicherlich sagen, wenn die da so eine Umfrage machen auf einer Datingplattform, werden vermutlich die Leute, die AfD-Anhänger sind, sich gegenseitig auch motivieren zu sagen, stimme da mal ab, damit die AfD kräftig da sind. Denn das werden ja die Medien aufgreifen, haben sie ja dann auch gestern getan. Und überall war das dann zu lesen, was ist los, die schwule Community wählt die AfD. Okay, da gibt es solche Mobilisierungstendenzen. Ich glaube aber trotzdem, dass da eine gewisse Trendenz drin liegt, dass überhaupt solche Zahlen zustande kommen. Und das ist glaube ich das, was du dort beschreibst. Und bedeutet ja dann auch, dass dieser Rechtsruck vollzogen ist eigentlich schon in den Köpfen. Und jetzt ist die Frage, wer übt ihn nochmal politisch in einer besonders harten Weise aus?
Ja, also die Ansprache, also Rechtsruck klingt immer so nach hochtrabend usw. Rechtsruck beginnt, wenn die Ansage ist, du hast dich in der Schule angestrengt, du hast dein Zimmer aufgeräumt, du hast dir einen Walkman gekauft, der ist ab jetzt deiner. Und sobald du ein BMW gekauft hast und vielleicht darüber nachdenkst, dir ein Haus zu kaufen, ist unsere Ansprache deine Ansprache. Wir werden dafür sorgen, dass keine Mörder auf der Straße stehen und dein Kind auf dem Schulweg angreifen. Wir werden dafür Sorge tragen, dass niemals jemand kommt und sagt, du willst deinem Sohn diese zwei Quadratmeter vererben, wir sorgen dafür, dass niemand da irgendetwas von abknabbt für den Staat. Das ist die Ansage. Die funktioniert und zwar auch dann, wenn man sagt, ja im Übrigen komme ich übrigens aus Ghana ursprünglich, aber das ist ja egal. Ja. Ich bin ja Held meines eigenen Schicksals jetzt gerade in diesem Moment, wo all das in Gefahr steht und dann kommt jemand und sagt, du und deine Familie, das ist uns heilig. Und man sagt sich, ja genau, ich bin der, der sich in der Schule angestrengt hat und nicht der Mörder. Also schlage ich mich auf diese Seite. Man kommt aus dieser Falle natürlich sehr schnell raus, wenn man sich nur, sagen wir mal, zehn Minuten am Tag mit jenseits des Horizontes und der eigenen Interessen beschäftigt. Aber wenn man das nicht macht, dann ist man leider zu dumm für die Demokratie. Also wir gehen da heute in diesem Buch durch, da wird es ja auch beschrieben. Der Mechanismus ist immer sehr viel einfacher als man glaubt. Man versucht ja immer die einfachsten, wahrscheinlich nur gefühlten intuitiven Mechanismen mit so überbordender Akademie und hier noch mal eine Studie und da noch mal irgendeine Theorie. Nein, man kann einfach kurz, also diese politischen Fragen aufzuklären, dafür reicht eine kurze Meditation. Deshalb ich auch mittlerweile denke, wenn ich so Karim Jostka sehe, wie sie ihre Talkshow moderiert oder Dunja Hayali, wie sie in der heutigen Sendung moderiert, einfach kurz 10 Minuten meditieren. Einfach kurz 10 Minuten in sich gehen. Man braucht nicht viel, um die Stolpersteine, über die die die ganze Zeit stolpern, einfach zu bewältigen. Es ist eigentlich gar nicht so kompliziert. Man muss nur ganz kurz mal über die eigenen Gefühlswelten so nachdenken und sich denken, die anderen sind genauso Menschen wie ich. Anstatt hier irgendwie, ah ja, Hanna hat mir das vorhin noch mal, das ist ja super interessant, das verbinde ich mal damit und dann trage ich das so in zwei Sätzen, die ich schnell als Moderation geschrieben habe, vorher funktioniert das nicht. Deswegen ja auch, wir kommen heute auch darauf zu sprechen, dieses Geplauder in dem Podcast, wo man nur einen Termin einhält und dann findet der Podcast statt und man sich nicht groß vorbereitet. Das sind die Erfolgsrezepte, weil das Publikum hört sich dem Podcast auch einfach so an als Geplauder nebenbei und hält nicht mal einen Termin ein, sondern drückt Zeit souverän auf Play, wenn man halt so weit ist. Und das Publikum da einfach zu matchen, ist ganz wichtig. Und das, was da stattfindet, ist nicht richtig im öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk zum Beispiel.
Und damit natürlich auch die Aufmerksamkeit auf ewig dieses Thema zu ziehen. Also es ist ja interessant, du musst ja, damit sich die POC auf der Straße, die gefragt wird, die Russlanddeutschen, die interviewt werden, die User einer Datingplattform, die gefragt werden und so, die musst du ja erstmal dazu bringen, dass sie als erstes, wenn sie eine politische Entscheidung treffen sollen, über Sicherheit und Migration nachdenken. Also das ist ja erstmal eine Leistung, die erbracht werden muss. Denn man könnte ja auch sagen, ich guck mir jetzt erstmal die Steuer an. Das wäre ja auch sehr naheliegend und auch an sich selbst gedacht, aber das wäre ja etwas, wo man dann wahrscheinlich zu anderen Ergebnissen käme.
Wir haben gesellt Geld als Gesundheit, so viele Sachen, Freundschaft. Wie finde ich meinen Lebenspartner, wie auch immer. Das sind so viele Fragen, die sich mit dem beschäftigen. Und dann wird er so, jetzt machen wir eine politische Wahl. Okay, was ist mit den Ausländern? Was ist mit der Grenze, die 800 Kilometer weit weg ist von mir und so weiter. Also es ist wirklich eine super Leistung. Erfordert eben auch, dass sich der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk in Deutschland komplett der AfD unterwirft.
Im Prinzip ja.
Also komplette Kapitulation.
Und dadurch werden ja auch Themen gar nicht besprochen.
Vielleicht müssen wir dieses Bild mal... Wir haben alle gesehen, wie Mark Zuckerberg als größter Medienunternehmer der Welt eine Kapitulationserklärung abgegeben hat.
Ja.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich Karamioska sehe, sehe ich quasi Karamioska mit so einem schwarzen Hemd, mit so einer Goldkette und Locken, wie sie sich komplett unterwirft. Also ich habe jetzt Alice Weidel zu Gast. Ich konnte da nichts dagegen machen. Ich habe nachgeguckt, also das interessiert alle Leute und jetzt stelle ich ihr eine Frage und wenn ich die Antwort nicht verstehe und ich glaube, sie verstehen ihn dann auch nicht, dann sage ich, ja dann reichen wir morgen den Faktencheck nach. Ja. So Punkt, das ist Kapitulation. Also da ist es dann einfach nicht zu machen, ist sehr viel besser.
Ja, ja, weil wir die ganze Zeit darüber reden, was die AfD für eine Reichweite auf TikTok bekommt. Ich brauche überhaupt gar keinen TikTok dafür, um die ganze Zeit AfD-Content wahrzunehmen. Ich brauche nur das öffentlich-rechtliche Fernsehen und noch das Privatfernsehen dazu einschalten. Und die Bild-Zeitung, die sich dann rühmt, dass sie eine Distanz zur AfD haben, ja ihr macht die ganze Zeit AfD-Themen und Inhalte. Ihr braucht die gar nicht noch mal. Also sie sagen dann, wir nehmen keine Werbegelder von der AfD an, um Wahlwerbung zu machen. Dann denke ich mir, ja die AfD wäre ja blöd bei euch noch mal Geld überhaupt abzugeben. Ihr macht ja die Werbung für die.
Es ist im Grunde überall derselbe Joke. Bei Horst und Hopf, die machen es halt explizit. Die sagen uns einfach, aber wir sagen euch nicht, wen wir wählen. Genau das ist auch Bild-Tenor. Die sagen mir auch nicht, wen sie da wählen.
Die wählen wahrscheinlich alle Linkspartei. Auch noch ein Thema, in der Bild-Zeitung stand es, ganz interessant, kommt dann mal so kurz auf. Mehrwertsteuererhöhung. Veronika Grimm findet, das ist eine ganz gute Idee. Rürup sagte auch, ist eine gute Idee. Politik schweigt sich dazu aus. Die Ansage wäre 3% Erhöhung. Also um 3%, das heißt, wir hätten eine Mehrwertsteuer von 22%. Das ist die Idee. Ich habe den großen Verdacht, dass wir über diese, das könnte natürlich auch noch sein, dass wir dieses Problem bekommen werden. Also du findest nichts dazu in den Wahlprogrammen, das sage ich gleich. Es gibt so ein paar Vorschläge für Senkungen auf Lebensmittel oder Gastronomie, solche Mövenpick-Steuern, sage ich mal, solche Modelle gibt es natürlich. Es gibt soziale Ideen von einer Null Mehrwertsteuer auf lebenswichtige Güter. Aber wir finden nicht etwas von einer Mehrwertsteuer-Erhöhung. Und eigentlich ist ja die Mehrwertsteuer-Erhöhung eine perfekte neoliberale Strategie. Du weißt, die wollen eigentlich immer mal an die Renten ran, können das nicht, weil sie da ihre Wähler haben. Du kannst die Renten erhöhen, kannst aber die Mehrwertsteuer zugleich erhöhen und dadurch hast du dann die Renten wieder abgeschöpft. Die Leute, die nicht reich sind, die besteuert man ja dann besonders. Das heißt also man entlastet mit der Mehrwertsteuer-Erhöhung reiche Leute. Ja, man kann sogar die Steuersenkungen für Reiche, die von der CDU ja geplant sind, kann man wunderbar finanzieren durch eine Mehrwertsteuer-Erhöhung. Jetzt werden manche sagen, naja, aber die Reichen zahlen doch auch Mehrwertsteuer. Die Sache ist nur, die zahlen ja nur einen Teil von ihrem Gehalt. Haben sie eine hohe Sparrate, sie investieren etc. Das heißt sie konsumieren ja keineswegs ihr gesamtes Geld. Während die Normalverdiener und Niedrigverdiener müssen ja ihren Lohn fast komplett verkonsumieren. Das heißt bei denen ist eine Mehrwertsteuer-Erhöhung ganz einfach zu rechnen. Sie haben drei Prozent weniger in ihrem Portemonnaie. Für Reiche gilt das nicht. Wenn die ein Steuergeschenk bekommen in der Form, dass sie eine niedrigere Einkommenssteuer zahlen müssen, die Unternehmenssteuer gesenkt wird und Vermögensteuer auch nicht kommt und Erbschaftssteuer noch weiter vernachlässigt wird, dann bekommen die so viel mehr Geld, dass das für die dann kein Problem ist, wenn die dann drei Prozent mehr zahlen müssen, wenn sie eine Rolex kaufen. Also das ist wirklich eine sehr, sehr ungerechte Steuer sowieso schon. Und man kann ja generell in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten sehen, wie diese Konsumsteuern immer angehoben wurden, während man Unternehmenssteuern und andere Steuern, die reiche belasten wurden, gesenkt hat. Und ich habe die große Sorge, dass dann unter einer Koalition mit Friedrich Merz, egal wer dann da drin im Boot sitzen wird, dass dann so etwas kommt und dass man das auch damit begründet, dass man sagt, ja uns sind die Hände sonst gebunden, uns tut das auch sehr weh, aber wir müssen es leider machen.
Ja, Themenvorschlag für Wohlstand für alle. Wir sagen ja immer, der Haushalt, der Staatshaushalt und der private Haushalt ist nicht eins. Nur der private Haushalt und der private Haushalt sind auch nicht eins. Es gibt private Haushalte, die Mehrwertsteuer-Erhöhungs- anfällig sind. Ja. Nämlich am Ende des Monats, bis dahin wird alles Geld ausgegeben und dann kommt ein Paycheck und dann geht es halt weiter. Und dann gibt es ja Haushalte, die Wert kaufen, Aktien oder sowas. Und Scott Geller wäre das letztens beschrieben, das ist wirklich sehr clever, wie das die Superreichen machen. Sagen wir mal die Mittelreichen bis Superreichen. Man kauft sich Wertgegenstände, die als Sicherheit in der Bank dienlich sind. Und dann holt man sich Kredite für ein, zwei Prozent. Also, das sind ja immer noch relativ niedrige Ziele. Was bedeutet, man muss niemals von den eigenen Wertbeständen abrücken, sondern man verschuldet sich mit ihrer Hilfe. Was bedeutet, dass man zum einen 100 Prozent Gewinne einfährt. Also diese Dividenden bleiben ja als Buchgeld-Sicherheit vorhanden. Sie werden ja nicht aktualisiert, liquidiert und dadurch fällt keine Abgeldungs-, keine Ertrags-, keine Einkommenssteuer, nichts fällt an. Also man hat einfach, man sieht abends Anja Kohl sagt einen Tagesthemen DAX 10 Prozent oben und man weiß, ich bin 10 Prozent reicher. Darauf fällt nichts, keine Steuer, nichts an. Und dann geht man zur Bank und holt sich als das ist meine Sicherheit ein Kredit in der Höhe, in der man Geld braucht und achtet einfach darauf, dass man nie unter Wasser ist, sondern immer die Sicherheit größer ist als das eigene Kreditvolumen, das man da aufruft und für diesen Kredit bezahlt man dann ein, zwei Prozent und damit ist man liquide. Oder aber man verrechnet einfach mit seinem Steuerberater oder seiner Anwaltskanzlei erstmal alle Ausgaben, die man hat gegen das eigene Einkommen. Da reicht man dann die Mehrwertsteuer erstmal weiter, deklariert das als Betriebsaufgabe, wie alles möglich ist. So werden alle Autos gekauft, 90 Prozent aller Autos. Man fragt sich immer, die Deutschen sind so arm, aber auf der Autobahn stehen immer nur Mercedes, Audi, BMW und so weiter. Das läuft ja alles über dieses, weil da gar kein Steuerlast anfällt, das wird betrieblich verrechnet und so weiter und so fort. Also es gibt auch Haushalt und Haushalt. Und Mehrwertsteuer betrifft eben nur den einen Haushalt. Und im anderen Haushalt, ob ich jetzt in meiner Rechnung, in der ich das einfach weiterreiche, 19, 21, 22 Prozent, dann reiche ich mir noch einen da.
Ja, die Unternehmen reichen es weiter. Es ist wirklich nur die private Rolex, die man sich dann kauft und da sagt man sich, die gönne ich mir. Naja, man kann sich auch sagen, ich habe so tolle Steuergeschenke jetzt bekommen. Ich zahle zehn Prozent weniger Einkommensteuer und die Kapitalertragssteuer wurde auch noch gesenkt. Da kann ich mir locker eine Rolex von kaufen und die drei Prozent Mehrwertsteuer habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen. Genau. Während wir hier wirklich eine Politik haben, die wieder die betrifft, die ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen müssen und mit dem wenigen Geld, das sie verdienen, dann sehen müssen, dass sie über die Runden kommen. Die sollen dann drei Prozent weniger bekommen. Also ich sehe das als eine große Gefahr an. Wird nicht thematisiert. Ist jetzt mal hier da in der Bildung so ein Vorschlag aufgegriffen, so als Meldung hat man da mal gelesen. Wird aber auch dem nicht weiter nachgegangen. Das ist eigentlich jetzt schon das Thema, so vorbereitet sein für das, was nach der Wahl geschieht. Und dann kann man sich Friedrich Merz schon genau vorstellen und kann sich auch vorstellen, wie alle mitmachen. Also das ist ja auch noch interessant. Wir wissen ja noch damals bei der letzten Mehrwertsteuererhöhung, war das ja so, man hatte 16 Prozent Mehrwertsteuer. Und dann gab es von der CDU den Vorschlag, sie um zwei Prozent zu erhöhen. Daraufhin sagte die SPD, never ever, das machen wir nicht mit. Dann machte man eine große Koalition mit CDU und SPD. Und die Mehrwertsteuer wurde nicht um zwei Prozent, sondern um drei Prozent angehoben.
Nach der Wahl hast du vier Jahre lang frei. Kannst du machen, was du willst. Sieht man jetzt auch in Amerika. Du musst nur den Wahlkampf durchstehen, siegreich. Danach kannst du machen, was du willst. Ja, nicht sehr gut für Deutschland, denn wir wählen ja demnächst. Ab dann sind wir mal gucken, auch irgend wem ausgeliefert, wie die Amerikaner Elon Musk. War sicher immer noch top Thema, liebe Journalisten. Ich will keine weiteren Texte zu Gaza hören, das ist alles so ein Unfug. Elon Musk ist das Thema. Gut, was lesen wir heute?
Wir lesen heute Zu Dumm für die Demokratie von Mark Schiritz. Das ist ein Buch, das die liberale Ordnung schützen will. Schiritz ist ja Zeitjournalist, der so in der Mitte und ein bisschen links steht, würde ich sagen. So würde man ihn vielleicht einordnen können.
Wenn man ihn noch einordnen muss. Ich bin ja sowieso...
Vielleicht brauchen wir es nicht. Jedenfalls ist es ein Buch, das fragt, sind wir zu dumm für die Demokratie? Diese Frage, will dieses Buch mal antworten. Wir werden darüber diskutieren, ob es das tut, beziehungsweise ob nicht auch andere Dummheiten ausgeplendet werden. Ja, total.
Aber es gibt eine klare Antwort auf die Frage, die auf dem Buchtitel steht.
Darauf gibt es eine klare Antwort. Ich würde diese Antwort nur vielleicht erweitern wollen.
Ja, das geht natürlich. Da bin ich total dafür.
Denn ich glaube, dass man es sich dann auch nicht zu einfach machen darf und indem man zum Beispiel dann zu sehr auf die AfD abzielt. Jedenfalls ist das ein gutes Debattenbuch, über das wir diskutieren können im Salon. Ich habe außerdem dabei ein Buch über Kolipris. Kolipris sind ganz besondere Vögel. Es gibt eine Schriftstellerin, die bei einer Kolipri-Rettung dabei war oder zwei Kolipris wurden gerettet. Und sie beschreibt wunderbar diese kleinen Tierchen und zeigt damit eine sehr stille Form des Umweltschutzes. Und es ist ein sehr, sehr schönes Buch, dass einem, man möchte es fast nicht sagen, aber es ist so, Hoffnung gibt. Dann habe ich einen Erzählungsband gelesen von Mesut Bayraktar. Der schreibt über Menschen, die ganz normale Menschen sind, die also von einer Mehrwertsteuer-Erhöhung betroffen werden. Er schreibt von einer Studentin hier in Deutschland, die ihr Studium damit finanziert, dass sie auch nebenher sich verkaufen muss. Er schreibt von zwei Brüdern. Der eine versucht eine akademische Karriere, der andere arbeitet und sieht ja auch, wie Entlassungen um ihn herum stattfinden. Er beschreibt von einem Arbeiter, der morgens ins Werk geht und weiß noch nicht, ob er am Abend noch Arbeit haben wird. Es sind wirklich die Ausbeutungsverhältnisse hier in Deutschland, wie sie sind. Aber zugleich ist da eine poetische Sprache, die sehr faszinierend ist. Die Lage heißt dieser Band. Darüber werden wir sprechen.
Ich kling für mich nach links, grün versifften Wogscheiß von über Leute, die ihr Zimmer nicht aufgeräumt haben.
So würde das wohl Horst und Hopf sagen, ja. Dann gibt es wieder einen Musik-Tipp. Diesmal die vier Jahreszeiten, würde man sagen, braucht man jetzt noch die vier Jahreszeiten. Brauchen wir da noch mal eine Neueinspielung?
Es ist Winter, klar.
Man braucht genau diese Einspielung. Dann ein Text über den Weltraum-Kolonialismus von Elon Musk und Donald Trump. Und es gibt eine sehr ausführliche Recherche von zwei Journalisten, die sich gefragt haben, warum wird eigentlich immer gesagt, die Ukrainer wollen kämpfen. Stimmt das überhaupt? Und die Antwort ist nein, das können wir uns vielleicht schon denken, aber die Zahlen, die dann hier genannt werden, sind wirklich noch einmal erschütternd und hochinteressant und aufschlussreich. Und ich hoffe, dass das vielleicht ein paar Leute auch mitbekommen, die bei Twitter immer unterwegs sind und immer genau wissen, wie sehr alle kämpfen wollen.
Wir lesen meinerseits dieses fantastische Buch Gemeinsinn, das ich allen empfehle als Lektüre, die jetzt gerade sich in Wahlkämpfen verstricken und sich fragen, worum geht es eigentlich gerade und auf welchen Fundamenten sollten meine Argumentationen basieren, wenn ich in einer Talkshow sitze und über ein Thema diskutiert wird und ich über dieses Thema gar nicht reden will, sondern über ein anderes. So, also es ist ein wahnsinnig orientierungsbietendes, sehr lesereiches, also da wird sozusagen durch eine ganze Bibliothek gestreift und uns zusammengesammelt, was wir wissen müssen. Wir lesen daraus Auszüge zu Karl Schmidt, Emanuel Kant und Omri Böhm, denn es regt auch sehr zum Denken an und wir müssen über den radikalen Universalismus noch mal neu nachdenken. Das werde ich gleich vorschlagen. Außerdem strotzt dieses Buch auch mit Beispielen. Man hat ja sehr häufig bei so etwas tiefergehenden theoretischen Denken, dass so das politische Denken aufgreift und so weiter. Ja, was hat das jetzt mit Östritz zu tun? Und dann gehen die einfach auf den Marktplatz von Dörfern zur Tafel und gucken sich das genau an und sagen, hier finden wir, was wir suchen und so. Also das ist wirklich fantastisch. Alle, die jetzt politische Diskussion führen, müssen dieses Buch in ihrem Bücherregal haben. Dann gehen wir kurz durch Bloombergs Podcast-Analyse. Darüber hatte ich auch schon Text geschrieben vor zwei Wochen. Wir gehen diese Zahlen noch mal durch, weil das unsere Fragestellung ist. Und Mark Zuckerberg auch sagt, es ist ganz erstaunlich, aber die Leute hören heute anderen Leuten zu. Also es ist nicht mehr Klaus Kleber und Joel Reed, sondern es sind jetzt neue Leute, die die Debatte trägen. Dann gibt es für mich als 200 Euro pro User von GPT die Möglichkeit, mir Deep Research-Dossiers zu erstellen. Ich habe also ein Dossier erstellt über den Filmkritiker Wolfgang M. Schmidt.
Wirklich?
Ja. Geh mal den Sing-Sagen und den Textverlauf durch, was über dich herausgefunden wurde im Internet.
Vielleicht Dinge, die ich noch gar nicht von mir selbst weiß.
Ja, das ist ganz interessant. Also egal, was man an Fragestellungen los wird, man kriegt so 2700 Worte, was schon, sagen wir mal, vier, fünf Zeitungsspalten, eine ganze Seite mit einem nicht allzu großen Bild ist, also viel. Und die Zeit hat neue Grundbegriffe vorgestellt. Das ist natürlich wieder so ein Text, der mich einfach fängt über so eine, sagen wir mal, etwas einfache Art und Weise. Aber es ist doch unter den sechs Begriffen einer dabei, das Sichtbarkeitsregime, dem wir eine kleine Aufmerksamkeit widmen zum Schluss. In den Salon kommt man über die Neuenzwanziger als Webseite. Wir sind also ein Podcast mit Webseite. Das ist sehr untypisch. Versucht mal einen Podcast runterzuladen und nicht nur bei Spotify anzuhören. Das ist bei uns also einfach möglich. neuenzwanziger.de. Da findet man alles und auch den goldenen Button in den Salon. Da kann man einfach folgen und wir haben eine Neuerung. Diejenigen, die Salon-Hörer schon sind, bekommen ab jetzt alle Inhalte dieses Podcasts im Salon. Also der öffentliche Feed hat zwar den öffentlichen Podcast, aber dieses Gespräch, was wir jetzt gerade führen, geht sozusagen pausenlos über in den Salon für Salonmitglieder, während es für Nicht-Salonmitglieder einfach abbricht. Und bisher auch für Salonmitglieder abbricht, die dann den Salon einzeln anklicken mussten. Ab jetzt machen wir es einfacher. Auch die Monatsfolge gibt es ab Februar im Salon. Und dieses Gespräch hier ist direkt einfach vorm Salon dran. Also man kann einfach weiterhören. Es macht wohl sehr viel einfacher und zwar vielfacher Wunsch.
Wer abonniert hat, muss jetzt nur noch einen einzigen Feed haben, und da alles andere fällt weg. Und die, die uns jetzt gerade noch jenseits diesseits, oder wie sagt man, also noch nicht hinter der Paywall hören, die haben also natürlich auch die Möglichkeit, dann so ein Abo abzuschließen und dann das Komplettpaket in einem RSS-Feed zu haben. Das geht wie gesagt über Steady, über diesen goldenen Button. Das geht aber auch, wenn man über Spotify diesen Podcast hört, da wird man auch zu Steady gleich weitergeleitet. Man kann den Podcast auch abonnieren, indem man bei Patreon schon ist, auch das ist möglich. Oder wer es bequem hat und bei Apple bleiben möchte, kann auch über Apple den Salon buchen.
So ist es. Und wir haben nachgeschaut, es gibt noch einige Termine für Herbst und Winter.
Es sind auf Plätze frei.
Ungefähr so 100. Viel ist nicht mehr von 800 insgesamt. Weshalb wir euch im Salon noch mal einen Sommertermin bekannt geben.
Ja, sag aber doch nochmal, gerade für alle, die noch zu dem normalen Live-Salon wollen, wo sie und wie sie da an Karten kommen. Also das sind ja, also der Märztermin ist völlig ausverkauft. Ein paar Restkarten gibt es noch für den Juni. Das ist der?
20 Tickets gibt es für den Juni noch am 20. Juni.
Am 20. Juni, ja.
Da sagt uns Wolfgang auch gleich im Salon, dass wir vorher in die Oper gehen. Aber nur für hartgesottene, diese Oper geht 5,5 Stunden. 19.9. gibt es noch Tickets und 19.12. ungefähr 100. Ja und dann sagen wir euch einen Sommersalon-Termin. Wolfgang hat ja schon ein Programm vorgeschlagen. Die E-Mail-Adresse unter der ihr Tickets bestellt für die vier Case-Termine nenne ich euch nicht, sondern die steht im Text, damit es nicht zu Transkriptionsproblemen kommt, wenn jetzt jemand nur zuhört, sondern in den Show-Notes dieses Podcasts stehen alle Termine und die E-Mail-Adresse ist genannt. So, Termine bekannt, um in den Salon überzuleiten. Und zwar als Klebstoff sozusagen. Zwischen unsere Diskussion, Rechtsruck, Merz macht quasi AfD-Politik und so weiter. Und der Frage, sind wir zu dumm, das zu verstehen, was da passiert? Hier mal Clips, die das wirklich sehr gut illustrieren. Wir haben auf der einen Seite Wolfgang Schmidt, der Olaf Scholz rechter Hand als Chef der Staatskanzlei, als Bundeskanzleramts ist, der also die echten politischen Geschäfte führt, der die Klammer ist zwischen Parlament und Kanzlerschaft. Und auf der anderen Seite Philipp Ronsheimer, Paul Ronsheimer, der mit dem Philipp Dings da diesen Podcast macht und in dem Fall jetzt Schmidt zum Gast hat. Und wir hören jetzt einfach heraus, wo die Schieflagen sind. Wir haben es ausführlich diskutiert. Wir können es jetzt mal hier richtig hören und sozusagen als Datengrundlage benutzen für unser Gespräch zum Buch. Denn das Problem, was das Buch behandelt, wird hier zu 100 Prozent deutlich. Also es ist einfach selten wahr, ist so klar. Fangen wir mal an, es sind insgesamt sechs Clips. Angeblich, das Gespräch verläuft schon eine Weile, sagt Ronsheimer, sagen Sie immer nur, was nicht geht, Herr Politiker.
Jetzt zuhört und sagt, das ist die Argumentation. Dann sag mal noch, Moment mal, Sie sind Kanzleramtschef. Sie haben ja auch Ministerpräsidenten, die SPD-Ministerpräsidenten sind und Sie beschreiben, was aus Grund von Urteilen nicht geht, was woanders nicht geht. Also Sie beschreiben immer, was nicht geht.
Und ich hab gerade versucht zu beschreiben, was wir alles gemacht haben. Und genau mit den Ministerpräsidenten, die dafür zuständig sind, haben wir ganz weitreichende Verabredungen getroffen.
So, also es sind irgendwelche Ministerpräsidenten zuständig, weitreichende Verabredungen wurden getroffen. Es geht um juristische Texte und so weiter und so fort. Marc Schiritz klärt uns ja darüber auch auf, dass es relativ selten wegen deutscher Grundgesetzgebung zu Asylverfahren kommt in Deutschland, sondern es sind Genver-Konventionen, Menschenrechtskartas und so weiter und so fort. Also internationales Recht, wo man jetzt nicht einfach drüber fliegen kann. So wir haben mal so ein Clash zwischen, ja aber wir haben doch Magdeburg erlebt und Erschaffenburg erlebt und dann sagt der andere, aber wir haben doch Ministerpräsidenten und wir haben doch internationales Recht.
Solling erlebt, wir haben Magdeburg erlebt, wir haben Erschaffenburg erlebt und ich könnte das weiterführen und wir würden hier lange sitzen. Der Eindruck, der entsteht, wenn wir sagen, das geht alles nicht, bedeutet doch gleichzeitig, dass wir bereit sind, das als in gewisser Weise normal anzuerkennen.
Niemals. Ich bin immer sehr dafür, dass man sich genau anguckt, was sind Ursachen und was sind Gründe und dann auch überlegt, was muss man tun.
Also hier geht es doch um...
Machen wir doch mal ein ganz einfaches Beispiel. Ich habe ja gesagt, ich bin da von Belgien gekommen, dann ist so ein Grenzübertritt, man hat da ein paar Polizisten aufgestellt, man wird runter getrostet auf 20, dauert ein paar Minuten, alle fahren aber durch. Man sieht auf der anderen Spur, die LKWs, die fahren auch alle durch, auch mit 20 kmh. Jetzt stellen wir uns mal vor, man würde das, was Friedrich Merz da so verspricht, tatsächlich machen. Man würde sagen, man muss jedes Auto checken, denn ich könnte ja jemand im Kofferraum haben. Man müsste in jeden LKW reinleuchten. Wir hätten Staus von Stunden. Wir haben ja diese EU einmal konstruiert, deshalb weil wir einen EU-Binnenhandel beschleunigen, verstärken, intensivieren wollten. Jetzt stellte man sich vor, man würde die Grenzen wieder so dicht machen, dichter als sie jemals waren, denn man müsste, um alles kontrollieren zu können, jeden einfach anhalten und da kann man nicht sagen, auch der Fahrrad mir aber gefallen, sondern nein, man muss überall reinleuchten, sind da hinten zehn Leute drin oder nicht. Das würde bedeuten, nicht nur, dass man zehntausende Polizisten mehr benötigen würde, sondern es würde bedeuten, dass man riesige Staus produziert, dass plötzlich die Importkosten und auch Exportkosten extrem steigen würden innerhalb der europäischen Länder, weil ja alles wieder mit Grenzverkehr ist. Man hat ja, wenn man sich mal ansieht, wo die Lkw-Routen und so weiter hergehen, die haben ja zwei, drei Grenzüberträge, die müssen Österreich und Deutschland und so weiter. Wenn die das alles immer unter solchen Kontrollen machen müssten, wäre das eine Katastrophe. Also das, was Friedrich Merz dort verspricht, ist nur Deklamation von irgendetwas, was sich gut anhört, vielleicht in Talkshows oder in Social Media Videos für manche Leute. Es ist aber politisch gar nicht umsetzbar. Das kann er aber nicht sagen, weil er sonst von Paul Ronzheimer hören würde. Ja, sie sagen uns immer, was nicht geht.
Umso einfacher die politische Lösung, umso komplizierter wird es in der Realität. Das sieht man ja gerade in Amerika. Also Trump hat jetzt einfach gesagt, ich bedrohe Kanada, Mexiko und China mit Zöllen. Dann hat irgendwie Trudeau so eine Rede gehalten. Ach, die lieben Amerikaner, das sind doch unsere besten Freunde und so weiter. Und man hat sich irgendwie so geeinigt und so zwei Stunden vorher. Nee, doch nicht. Nur China hat dann gesagt, ja gut, wir reden erstmal nicht mit euch. Wir machen auch einfach Zölle. Wir lassen uns darauf ankommen. Ja. So, jetzt bestellen die Amerikaner aber Waren aus China, die in 1,3 Milliarden Paketen münden, die alle bislang unter einer, also 800 Dollar Warenwert gilt als Grenze. Erst danach greifen die ganzen Zollgesetzgebungen. So, jetzt sind also nicht nur diese 10% Zoll.
Zoll ist ja Zoll schon bei, glaub ich, 20, 25 Dollar. Hält an bei diesen Tegu-Versendungen.
Ja, also Temo und Shi'in haben davon profitiert, dass es so eine 800 Dollar Grenze gibt. Alles darunter wird pauschal nicht, also wird sozusagen als Camps aus dem amerikanischen Markt. Ja doch, das waren 800 Dollar. Was zu dem Problem führt, dass diese neuen Zölle, also die neue Regelung, die neue Executive Order, nicht nur diese Zölle von 10% deklariert, sondern auch diese Zollausnahme für einzelne Lieferungen aufhebt. Was bedeutet, alle 1,3 Milliarden jährlichen Pakete müssen jetzt begutachtet werden. So, und was macht der Postal Service in Amerika? Er sagt, das ist uns zu viel Arbeit, das schaffen wir nie, wir lassen nichts mehr durch. Ja. So, jetzt sitzen einfach sehr viele Menschen in Amerika da, haben Sachen bestellt, die nicht geliefert werden. So, damit, also das war jetzt auch nicht Trumps Ansehen, aber die einfache Lösung zu sagen, ok, da machen wir jetzt die Grenze zu, ja dann ist die Grenze halt dann wirklich zu in dem Fall. Jetzt betrifft es erstmal nur die Freizügigkeit dieser Pakete. Also Wien möchte keine englischen wissenschaftlichen Arbeiten mehr, ist sozusagen, das ist das Niveau auf dem man da nachkommt.
Ja, also ich mein man muss sich das mal vorstellen mit dem Lkw-Verkehr, man würde den derart kontrollieren wollen, dann müsste eigentlich Friedrich Merz sagen, ja wir haben da jetzt ganz restriktive Maßnahmen vor, das kostet den Steuerzahler 100 Milliarden. Aber dafür stellen wir auch sicher, dass hier nicht einer reinkommt, der das Bürgergeld kassiert, obwohl er es eigentlich gar nicht haben dürfte. Kostet aber 100 Milliarden.
Genau, also keine Migration bedeutet kein frisches Gemüse im Supermarkt. So und das müsste eigentlich gar Mioska durchdiskutieren. Und zwar nicht nur mit Politikern, die dann eine Meinung dazu haben, sondern mit Leuten, die uns Wählern beschreiben, was das bedeutet.
Ja.
Und nicht und so weiter. So, jetzt ist der Schmidt da und möchte über Details reden, aber Paul Ronzheimer nicht.
Er tritt nach den Dublin-Regeln nach sechs Monaten, nachdem der das Gesuch hier gestellt hat, sogenannter Selbsteintritt ein und Deutschland wird zuständig. Und dann werden wir sie nicht mehr los. Es gibt aber eine Möglichkeit, die heißt nämlich, wenn derjenige als flüchtig ausgeschrieben wird, verlängert sich diese sechs Monatsfrist auf 18 Monate. Und mit dem neuen europäischen Asylsystem verlängert sie sich übrigens auf drei Jahre. Und wir müssen nicht mal mehr warten, bis der Dublin-Staat sagt, jawohl, wir sind zuständig, sondern wir können dem einfach mitteilen, nach unseren Vorstellungen seid ihr zuständig. Wir müssen die also nur noch notifizieren. Also eine deutliche Verbesserung. Deswegen ärgert es mich so, dass wir dieses Umsetzungsgesetz für die europäischen Asylringen jetzt nicht im Bundestag mit den Stimmen der CDU und der FDP beschlossen haben. Und dann ist es bei dem Erschaffenburg-Fall genau das gleiche. Auch da war wieder Bulgarien zuständig. Die hatten sogar erklärt, jawohl, wir übernehmen ihn. Und dann hat es, weil die Übermittlung lange gedauert hat, weil das Verfahren auch im Bundesamt für Migration und Flüchtlinge zu lange gedauert hat und weil dann die bayerischen Behörden nicht schnell gehandelt haben, wieder dieses Selbsteintrittsrecht und im Falle des Erschaffenburger Täters ist der ja auch auffällig gewesen, der ist den Behörden bekannt gewesen. Da gibt es das sogenannte Psych-KG, also das psychisch kranke Gesetz, wieder ein Landesgesetz, das vorsieht, dass Leute, die psychisch auffällig werden, in Gewahrsam genommen werden, Amtsärzten vorgeführt werden können.
Und dennoch hat Friedrich Merz ja einen Punkt, wenn er sagt, dadurch, dass weiter sehr viele Menschen nach Deutschland kommen, weil es sind ja weiterhin auch Großstädte. Wie viele haben wir im Vergleich?
Bla, bla, bla. Also er nennt die alle Gesetze, alle Zuständigkeiten, selbst das psychisch kranken Gesetz und so.
Ja, wundert, dass er das alles kennt.
Er ist Staatskanzlei, Bundeskanzler, Amtschef und so. Aber ich merke da nicht trotzdem den Punkt, dass wenn noch Leute kommen, ja genau, also klar, wenn noch Leute kommen, also wenn wir die Grenze nicht komplett zumachen. Schmidt versucht hier weiter sein Bestes, auch nochmal diesen Entschließungsantrag und diese Ankündigungspolitik als zu entlarven, als das was ist.
Es geht schon um konkretes Handeln. Es geht darum, dass man diese ganzen vielen Stellschrauben, die man bis an den Anschlag drehen muss, auch tatsächlich dreht. Und da kommt man nicht mit einem Entschließungsantrag und mit so einer martialisch vorgetragenen Forderung durch, die in der Praxis nicht geht. Sie ist rechtswidrig. Sie würde dazu führen.
Da gibt es unterschiedliche Ansichten, das muss ich nochmal einführen.
Aber es gibt eine herrschende Meinung. Es gibt die Gerichtsurteile. Es gibt eine verschwindende Mindermeinung. Und meine Sorge ist, wenn jetzt dieser Eindruck erweckt wird, es sei alles ganz einfach. Man müsse nur den Zauberstab nehmen und sagen, wir machen die Grenzen dicht. Und dann kommen am nächsten Tag doch welche, weil du 3800 Kilometer Grenze gar nicht lückenlos überwachen kannst.
Die Bundespolizei, sie kann das?
Nein, die Bundespolizei sagt nicht, sie kann die 3800 Kilometer Grenze lückenlos überwachen. Sie kann das machen, was wir jetzt ja gemacht haben. Wir haben Grenzkontrollen seit Oktober 2023. Das hat dazu geführt, dass wir jetzt über 40.000 Zurückweisungen gemacht haben. Wenn Herr Merz dann sagt, andere Staaten würden das auch machen. Ich hab's mir jetzt noch mal genau angeguckt. Das stimmt einfach nicht. Andere Staaten machen exakt das, was wir machen, nämlich verschärfte Grenzkontrollen. Auch da übrigens, die muss man alle sechs Monate in Europa beantragen bzw. notifizieren und muss immer wieder begründen, warum es nötig ist. Das haben wir gemacht.
Aber aus Ihrer Sicht, Herr Schmidt, wie viele Menschen kann Deutschland weiter jedes Jahr aufnehmen?
637.
Es ist wirklich absurd. So jetzt hören wir hier nochmal Wolfgang Schmidt, der versucht sein Bestes. Und während wir das hören, er macht jetzt ein größeres Argument, denken wir, okay, der verlässt jetzt diesen Posten und Carsten Linnemann wird als Chef des Bundeskanzleramts da einziehen.
Da bin ich wirklich der Meinung, dass wir auch daran nicht rütteln sollten. Wir sollten weiterhin für Menschen in Not da sein. Das ist unsere Aufgabe als Menschheit. Und gerade Deutschland hat da eine Verantwortung.
So, das ist glaube ich der letzte. Das ist sozusagen die aussterbende Generation. Solange noch Holocaust-Überlebende da waren, konnte man solche Leute im Kanzleramt hören. Demnächst einfach, nee, also ein totes Kind grenze zu. Und es wird ja ein ganz vehement, es sind ja alle Podcasts voll, Ronsheimer, Gordon Rypinski heute morgen, ganz energisch, aber da ist ein Kind gestorben. Wo man denkt, ja genau, da ist ein Kind gestorben. So und deswegen machen wir jetzt, verschließen wir uns vor der Welt. Also wo ist denn da überhaupt der innertliche Zusammenhang? Geschweige denn, wieso trägst du es so vor? Also ist doch...
Und in einer Weise, dass man wählen kann, jeweils zwischen tabula rasa und Vollkatastrophe oder was ist das? Also das ist ja ein hochdysfunktionales System, das man dort mit Friedrich Merz etablieren wird. Es ist ja nicht so, das kann man ja in den USA gut sehen, dass dann alles funktioniert, dass man sagen kann, es ist eine fürchterlich rechte Politik, aber sie funktioniert in irgendeiner Weise, dass man sagt, das ist ein handlungsfähiger Staat. Nein, diese Leute treiben einen ja in die Katastrophe rein, weil sie ja gar nicht diese anderen Dinge mitbedenken, die da sind. Also das ist ja einfach irrsinnig zu glauben, dass es so einfach ginge. Selbst wenn man das wollen würde, was wir jetzt nicht wollen, aber so müsste man doch eigentlich darüber reden. Und ich finde das Interessant, dass auch Journalisten, die ja doch ein bisschen rumkommen und die da wahrscheinlich auch den ein oder anderen Grenzübertritt haben, die ja jetzt nicht in der Eifel leben auf dem Bauernhof und sagen, die sollen man die Grenzen dicht machen, weil man selbst noch nie im Ausland war. Das sind ja Leute, die auch die ganze Zeit hin und her reisen. Die müssten doch eigentlich verstehen, dass das umsetzbar so einfach nicht ist.
Vor allem Andrea Nahles macht ja jetzt eine Pressekonferenz nach der anderen, in der sie immer wieder diese Arbeitsmarktzahlen nennt und immer wieder darauf hinweist, die Einzigen, die hier Wachstum bringen, sind ausländische Arbeitskräfte. Es gehen Deutsche in Rente und wir stellen Ausländer ein, weil es sind ja keine Deutschen da. So wenn man jetzt als Journalist eins plus eins ist zwei, wenn man dabei bleiben möchte und man stellt fest, also Remigration geht gar nicht, dann muss man für sich kurz feststellen, ach so Remigration ist einfach von heute in die Vergangenheit gedacht. Diejenigen, die schon kamen, kommen nicht. Das was Friedrich Merz hier macht, ist Demigration. Ab heute kommt keiner mehr. Das ist genau dasselbe. Das ist nur das eine Mal nach vorne und das andere Mal nach hinten gerechnet. Aber Remigration wie die AfD und Demigration wie Friedrich Merz führt einfach ökonomisch wirklich in den Abgrund. Wir haben noch keine KI-Roboter, sie hat, Elon Musk hat sie uns noch nicht vorgestellt, die Enno, der an der Kasse sitzt, ein LKW fährt oder was auch immer, den ersetzt. Nun wird es auch die nächsten 20 Jahre nicht geben.
Und es wird auch keinen Bürokratieabbau geben mit FDP und CDU bei gleichzeitiger Erhöhung der Grenzmaßnahmen und der Totalüberwachung von allen.
Grenze zu ist Bürokratie pur.
Ja.
Also das ist einfach, das ist nicht nur, wir stellen da Polizisten hin, sondern die brauchen auch eine Handlungsgrundlage.
Das geht nur durch Bürokratie. Diese Befugnisse, die da neu geschaffen werden müssen und so, das ist einfach, ja, das wird nicht gut ausgehen. Die promptet einem auch nicht GPT mal schnell hin, nur weil es in juristischen Fragen gut ist. Ein letzter Clip. Schmidt versucht es mal so auf den Punkt zu bringen. Es ist aber Rondsheimers Podcast, es führt nirgendwo hin.
Das Thema ist ja kaputt offenbar.
Ja, aber das ist ein bisschen meine Schwierigkeit, dass jetzt immer dann, wenn man ins Konkrete geht, gesagt wird, ja, aber das geht alles nicht.
Naja, aber ganz offensichtlich geht das ja nicht.
Ja, aber man drückt sich dann vor der harten Arbeit, die nämlich bedeutet, dass man jedes einzelne Gesetz angucken muss, dass man mit den Behörden darüber streiten muss, dass zwei Drittel der Ausländerbehörden nicht digitalisiert sind, dass man darüber reden muss, dass es nicht genug Haftplätze gibt. Ja, das haben wir genau gemacht. Aber nochmal, das ist die Aufgabe der Länder und das ist die Aufgabe der Kommunen.
Ja, so, sie meinen ja drei Jahre an der Regierung. Ja, als Regierung kann man was machen? Gesetze schreiben. Nur Gesetze umsetzen, das ist halt auch ein Thema. So, wenn man Gesetze hat, die man nicht umsetzt, dann ist es ein Umsetzungsproblem. Und wenn man dann nochmal neue Gesetze schreibt, vergrößert man nur das Umsetzungsproblem, aber löst gar nichts. Ein Gestrampel hier an diesen Themen. Oder Ronsheimer, es ist natürlich eine andere Wortwahl und eine andere Emotionalität. Aber das ist im Grunde Philipp Hopf inhaltlich. Eins zu eins. Wieso machen sie die Grenzen nicht zu? Wir haben doch Aschaffenburg und Magdeburg erlebt. Ist ein Kind nicht zu viel? Und so weiter und so fort.
Ja, ich finde das sehr so interessant, dass er ja jemand ist, der diesen Friedrich-Merz-Kurs zum einen kritisiert hat, mit dieser Brandmauer, die jetzt hier eingerissen wurde. Er aber dann hier zugleich doch den einen großen Hebel sehen möchte, der umgelegt wird, damit diese Probleme sich alle in Wohlgefallen auflösen. Das geht ja nicht zusammen.
Nee, geht auch nicht zusammen und die These bleibt, Friedrich-Merz ist schon AfD-Politik. Das ist schon jenseits der Brandmauer.
Ja. Also diese Diskussion über die Brandmauer und dass sie jetzt nicht mehr da ist, also wir reißen jetzt mal diskursiv die Brandmauer ab und sagen, die brauchen wir jetzt nicht mehr, sondern wir bewerten jetzt einzelne politische Positionen. Sind es AfD-Positionen oder nicht, egal wer sie vorträgt. Genauso haben wir erkannt, mit der klassischen Identitätspolitik kommen wir nicht weiter, weil auch die Leute, die eine marginalisierte Identität haben, durchaus bereit sind zum Beispiel rechts zu wählen. Und da müssen wir auch sagen, dann sind die wohl auch rechts. Dann sind die nicht eigentlich aber ganz toll und haben sich dann nur verirrt, sondern die sind dann wohl auch für eine rechte Position empfänglich und halten diese für richtig.
Und was in der Vergangenheit war, ist egal. Es ist niemand mehr aus der 19, was weiß ich, 95er-CDU geschweige denn am Leben.
Ja.
So, diese Parlamente sind ausgetauscht und diese Menschen sind dann auch irgendwann gestorben.
Ja. Also man braucht jetzt auch nicht die ganze Zeit nochmal zu twittern, wie schön war das mit Heiner Geißler und Norbert Blüm. Ja, alles gut und schön. Aber das ist jetzt nicht die CDU, die wir jetzt gerade haben.
Ja, genau.
Ja, das ist wie bei der Fußball-Nationalmannschaft. Da kann man auch nicht sagen, Mensch, das sind ja hier die Jungs.
Kann man mal an die Bremer einwechseln?
Ja, und Jürgen Klinsmann, die sind halt nicht da.
Genau, die sind einfach nicht da. So, wir gehen jetzt in den Salon. Wir lesen zu dumm für die Demokratie. Und ich hänge dann das Gemeinsinn-Buch an. Denn wenn man das gelesen hat, stellt man sich andere Fragen zur CDU. Nicht die, die Karin Mioska sich stellt als Fortschritt.
Ich bin gespannt.